Edward Norton was deeply affected by the experience
of making American History X, partly due to
the film's dark subject matter, and partly
because the production was a very troubled
one.
Here's why the actor was never quite the same
after making this film.
In 1996, Norton's performance in Primal Fear
established him as a formidable talent, but
it was his starring role in the 1998's American
History X that truly showcased his talents.
In the film, Norton plays Derek Vinyard, a
neo-Nazi who abandons his ideology after spending
some time in prison.
He then tries to prevent his younger brother,
Danny, played by Edward Furlong, from following
in his footsteps.
As Norton told GQ in 2019:
"The film was, like, even the poster was iconic.
It was a Shakespearean type of a story by
design."
It's rare that an actor has to step in and
edit the film they're starring in, but that's
exactly what Edward Norton ended up doing.
That's because the making of American History
X proved to be almost as controversial as
the film itself…and the film was plenty
controversial.
"Come on, man!"
"Put it on the curb, right now!"
In the middle of the editing process, director
Tony Kaye had some serious creative differences
with the production company New Line Cinema.
Kaye had previously worked as an advertising
director, and his experience in that industry
reportedly affected his editing decisions.
In fact, David McKenna, the film's screenwriter,
told The Telegraph that:
"[Kaye] literally destroyed the movie.
It was a commercial."
In the hopes of salvaging the film, Norton
stepped in and began working with Kaye, but
they were constantly at odds with one another.
However, many of Norton's edits did wind up
in the final cut of the film.
It was a new experience for Norton, but the
skill came in handy later: He ended up co-editing
the 2005 neo-Western Down in the Valley, a
film he also starred in.
After filming wrapped on American History
X, director Tony Kaye was very bitter towards
Edward Norton, and he wasn't shy about letting
the media know his thoughts.
The Telegraph quotes him saying that,
"[Norton is] a narcissistic dilettante, obsessed
with his image, obsessed with screen time...I
was going to take Hollywood by storm, and
I would have but for that buffoon."
Keep in mind, Kaye doesn't seem particularly
modest himself.
"I'm a storyteller.
So, you know, making a television commercial
is telling a story of sorts."
Thanks to all the drama behind the scenes
during the filming of American History X,
Norton earned a reputation for being "difficult"
to work with, but the actor rejects that characterization.
As he told The Telegraph:
"Difficult is really a question of semantics.
You can use that word or you can say rigorous,
committed, you can put it other ways.
And I'll tell you a very true thing.
None of what I would call the genuine talents
I've worked with, directors, have ever called
me difficult."
In a 2014 interview with Dan Rather, Edward
Norton confessed that,
"Making American History X was really hard.
It was, it was a guerilla kind of experience."
Norton put in some serious hours at the gym
to convincingly play Derek.
As Men's Workout reports,
"The actor gained 30 pounds of muscle in just
three months."
The magazine quotes Norton as saying,
"I knew this guy was going to have to be really
physically fearsome and defined by rage…arming
himself against his own emotional pain, and
this body he’s created is the physical manifestation
of that."
After the film was released, people suddenly
perceived Norton as bigger, stronger, and
more intimidating.
As he said on The Tim Ferriss Show in 2016,
"Doing that film created the strangest distortion
of perception on me."
He went on to say:
"It's unbelievable, the degree to which that
film and the magic of camera and art and black
and white photography and all these things
made a lot of people think that I was a larger
and tougher person than I am."
It sounds like Edward Norton has never been
too concerned about box office returns.
He'd much rather participate in films that
make a real cultural impact.
To hear him say it, American History X is
a film that really managed to capture the
zeitgeist, and he's proud to have been a part
of it.
In 2010, he told Slash Film:
"A lot of films are more successful financially
than Fight Club or American History X, but
those films meant more to people and continue
to.
To me, if I can make a couple of films that,
looking back, people say, 'Yeah, that’s
what our generation felt like at that moment.
That’s a good document,' then I’m content."
In a 2016 interview with BET, Norton was asked
whether he thinks the issue of racism has
changed since making the film in 1998.
He responded:
"To a degree we're not always comfortable
acknowledging this current of racism sits
under the surface."
He added that anxiety is often the cause of
those feelings, saying people, quote, "have
anxieties and they look for a target."
Derek goes through quite a dramatic personal
transformation in American History X, and
that journey is one of the things that really
excited Edward Norton about the character.
As he told Charlie Rose in 1998:
"That's the challenge of a role like that,
or the appeal of it for me."
He goes on to explain that,
"[It's] not even so much just the one very
extreme manifestation of this guy, but more
the emotional distance that he travels."
But Norton had to do more than convincingly
portray Derek's hatred.
He also had to create a nuanced character
who could learn how to become a more open-minded
person throughout the course of the film.
Ultimately, Norton interpreted Derek Vinyard
as a classically tragic figure:
"Let's look at someone who ruins all of the
potential in his life because of rage."
Norton also wanted audiences to see something
of themselves in Vinyard, despite the extreme,
and extremely ugly, nature of his character.
In 1999, he told The Guardian:
"An all-too-common reaction to something like
racism is to hate the act so much you dismiss
the person.
But in this film you're forced to confront
the complexity of the character and his tragedy."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.